This episode contains strong language and mature themes. If you're listening with young kids, I strongly urge you to save this one for later. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's an old saying, the best things in life are illegal, immoral, or fattening. There's another way to think about this. Many things that give us pleasure, sex, food, adventure, they contain risks. As a smart species, we've come up with ways to minimize those risks, condoms, seat belts,
本期节目包含粗俗语言和成人主题。如果您正与年幼的孩子一起收听，我强烈建议您稍后再听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。有句老话，生活中最美好的事物要么违法，要么不道德，要么让人发胖。还有另一种思考方式。许多给我们带来快乐的事物——性、食物、冒险——都包含风险。作为一个聪明的物种，我们已经想出了将这些风险降至最低的方法，比如避孕套、安全带、
drugs to lower cholesterol. But something interesting happens as we do this. As we move the risk-benefit calculation for each activity away from the risk end of the spectrum to the benefit end of the spectrum, we imagine people will become safer. Seat belts, for example, will keep drivers from getting hurt. Now, that would be true if people kept doing things exactly the way they did before. But some people make another calculation. If putting seat belts and cars means you are likely to survive a crash, there's now
降低胆固醇的药物。但当我们这样做时，发生了一些有趣的事情。当我们把每项活动的风险收益计算从风险端向收益端转移时，我们想象人们会变得更安全。例如，安全带可以防止驾驶员受伤。如果人们保持和以前完全一样的行为方式，那确实如此。但有些人会做出另一种计算。如果给汽车装上安全带意味着你更有可能在车祸中幸存，那么现在
a temptation to go faster. An ocean swimer might go out a little further when a life card is nearby. Football players who know their heads are protected by helmets might start to hit a little harder. This phenomenon has a curious name. Economists call it moral hazard. It's a bit of a misnomer because moral hazard has little to do with morality. It's about what happens when you move the risk-benefit calculation to make things safer, and people respond by taking more risks.
就有了超速的诱惑。当救生员在附近时，海里的游泳者可能会游得远一点。知道头部有头盔保护的橄榄球运动员可能会开始撞得更猛。这种现象有一个奇怪的名字。经济学家称之为“道德风险”。这有点用词不当，因为道德风险与道德几乎没有关系。它是关于当你为了让事情更安全而改变风险收益计算时，人们会通过承担更多风险来做出反应。
So there's a paper, a while back by Sam Peltzmann that kind of lays out the classic case of moral hazard that economists like to point to. This is economist Jennifer Doliak at Texas A&M University. And his idea was that when seatbelts first became required in cars, I think most people would assume when you have seatbelts that's unambiguously a good thing, it's going to save lives. And he saw that and thought, if you have a seatbelt,
所以，萨姆·佩尔茨曼（Sam Peltzmann）很久以前写过一篇论文，提出了经济学家喜欢指出的道德风险的经典案例。这是德克萨斯农工大学的经济学家詹妮弗·多利亚克（Jennifer Doliak）。他的观点是，当汽车首次强制要求安装安全带时，我想大多数人会认为，当你有了安全带，这无疑是一件好事，它会挽救生命。他看到了这一点，并认为，如果你有安全带，
maybe you drive a little bit more recklessly. If you have a seatbelt, maybe you drive a little bit more recklessly. Sam Peltzmann found that while drivers were safer because of seatbells, they also drove more recklessly. That would pedestrian's at risk. He argued that the safety benefits of seatbells were cancelled out when you took this into account. Now subsequent studies have challenged this finding, but the seatbelt example illustrates the dilemma posed by moral hazard. Should you make things safer if people are just going to take more risks, or should you allow people to face the consequences of their actions
也许你开车会更鲁莽一点。如果你有安全带，也许你开车会更鲁莽一点。萨姆·佩尔茨曼发现，虽然驾驶员因为安全带而更安全了，但他们开车也更鲁莽了。这让行人处于危险之中。他认为，当你考虑到这一点时，安全带带来的安全益处就被抵消了。现在随后的研究对这一发现提出了挑战，但安全带的例子说明了道德风险带来的困境。如果人们只会承担更多风险，你是否应该让事情变得更安全？还是你应该允许人们通过取消安全措施来承担其行为的后果？
by doing away with safety measures? This dilemma has political dimensions. Liberals tend to say the more safety measures, the better. Conservatives worry about the negative consequences that interventions might have on personal responsibility. So, are safety measures useful? The answer is, it depends. They can be safety measures that cause so much moral hazard that they make things worse. And they can be other interventions where the benefits far outweigh the risks.
这种困境具有政治层面。自由派倾向于认为安全措施越多越好。保守派则担心干预措施可能对个人责任产生的负面影响。那么，安全措施有用吗？答案是，视情况而定。有些安全措施可能会导致如此大的道德风险，以至于让情况变得更糟。也可能存在其他干预措施，其收益远大于风险。
Today we consider this dilemma in the context of a deadly public health crisis. I know I was dead for four minutes by the time the ambulance got there, but they revived me with Narcan. The opioid epidemic. He's playing Russian with men. They knew where the good, the good, the good. A grain of smalls, a piece of salt can kill a human, and it is 10,000 times more potent than morphine.
今天，我们将在致命的公共卫生危机的背景下考虑这一困境。我知道救护车到达时我已经死了四分钟，但他们用纳洛酮（Narcan）救活了我。阿片类药物流行。他在玩俄罗斯轮盘赌。他们知道哪里有好的，好的，好的。一粒盐那么小，就能杀死一个人，而且它的效力是吗啡的10,000倍。
They would haul us to get that shit, and they figure, okay, well I'll just do a little bit so it won't hurt me. Life, death and trade-offs. This week on Hidden Brain. The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention recently released an astonishing statistic. It estimates that in 2017, about 72,000 people died from drug overdoses. The vast majority of these deaths were caused by overdoses of heroin and other opioids. How do you understand the magnitude of 72,000 debts? I don't know, but I can tell
他们会拖着我们去弄那玩意儿，他们想，好吧，我只用一点点，这样就不会伤害我。生命、死亡和权衡。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。美国疾病控制与预防中心最近发布了一项惊人的统计数据。据估计，2017年约有72,000人死于药物过量。绝大多数死亡是由海洛因和其他阿片类药物过量引起的。你如何理解72,000人死亡的严重性？我不知道，但我可以告诉你
you one story. It unfolds in a tidy ranch home in Frederick, Maryland. My producer, Jenny Schmitt and I, have made the hour-long drive from Washington, DC. We sit down at the kitchen table and start with introductions. Yes, my name is Hope Troxill. Hello, my name is Pete Troxill. Hoping Pete Troxill live in a neighborhood on a hill just outside of town. I've been here all my life, and my husband and I both. We've been married 46 years, lived in the same area. Hope exudes a comforting warmth. She's the kind of person you want to hug.
一个故事。它发生在马里兰州弗雷德里克市一栋整洁的牧场式住宅里。我的制片人珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmitt）和我从华盛顿特区开车一小时来到这里。我们坐在餐桌旁，开始做自我介绍。是的，我叫霍普·特罗克西尔（Hope Troxill）。你好，我叫皮特·特罗克西尔（Pete Troxill）。霍普和皮特·特罗克西尔住在城外山上的一个社区里。我一生都住在这里，我和我丈夫也是。我们结婚46年了，一直住在同一个地区。霍普散发着一种令人欣慰的温暖。她是那种你想拥抱的人。
Pete is tall and reserved with long white hair and a thick white beard. It's not easy for them to share their story. Hope fidgets. Pete clenches his hands. They begin by telling us about the life they once had. A life that made sense. Their first child was their son Jeremy. He's very easy going. He doesn't get upset. He's very quiet. He'd never said a whole lot when he was young.
皮特身材高大，性格内向，留着长长的白发和浓密的白胡子。对他们来说，分享他们的故事并不容易。霍普坐立不安。皮特紧握双手。他们开始向我们讲述他们曾经拥有的生活。一种有意义的生活。他们的第一个孩子是儿子杰里米（Jeremy）。他非常随和。他不会心烦意乱。他非常安静。他年轻时话不多。
Four years later, Alicia arrived. My daughter is more of a strong person. She was determined more so than my son. Alicia was self-possessed, outgoing, a people person. She took risks, like the time when she was just seven, and decided she wanted to compete in a beauty pageant. Hoping Pete drove her to Virginia. Pete wore a tux.
四年后，艾丽西亚（Alicia）出生了。我的女儿是一个更坚强的人。她比我儿子更有决心。艾丽西亚很有主见，外向，是个善于交际的人。她喜欢冒险，比如她七岁那年，决定参加选美比赛。霍普和皮特开车送她去弗吉尼亚州。皮特穿了一件燕尾服。
Of course she didn't win, but she was so upset. But we had to tell her that, you know, life is full of disappointments, but you got to go on and you got to move on. And she did, and she got over, she has seven, eight years old, she got over it and... She came in the top 10. She was in the top 10. She didn't come in the first place,
当然她没有赢，但她非常难过。但我们不得不告诉她，你知道，生活充满了失望，但你必须继续前进，你必须走出来。她做到了，她克服了，她七、八岁时，她克服了它，而且……她进入了前10名。她进入了前10名。她没有获得第一名，
but she was in the top 10 out of the girls. Do you remember what she wore? I remember she had little gown on, but it was, it had the little crown thing and all that. I can't remember what color but it was a little long gown and she's just so cute. That memory of the little daughter in her long gown still makes them both smile.
但她在女孩中进入了前10名。你还记得她穿什么吗？我记得她穿了一件小礼服，上面有小皇冠之类的东西。我不记得是什么颜色了，但那是一件长长的小礼服，她看起来太可爱了。那个穿着长礼服的小女儿的记忆至今仍让他们两人微笑。
Hope says as the kids grew older, they stayed close with their parents. Jeremy started working for his dad's trucking business. Hope says she and Alicia will like two peas in a pod. You know, she had to call me every day or I had to be on the phone with her. After Alicia finished high school, Hope convinced her to apply for a job at Ford Detrek, a nearby army installation. Hope worked there too. Alicia started as a cleaning person. Within a couple years, she was walking in the mail room.
霍普说，随着孩子们长大，他们与父母保持着亲密关系。杰里米开始为他父亲的货运公司工作。霍普说她和艾丽西亚就像两颗豌豆一样亲密。你知道，她必须每天给我打电话，或者我必须和她通电话。艾丽西亚高中毕业后，霍普说服她去附近的陆军基地福特德特里克（Fort Detrick）申请一份工作。霍普也在那里工作。艾丽西亚最初是一名清洁工。几年之内，她就在收发室工作了。
She was thriving. She met her soon-to-be husband, and she was pregnant with twins. And my daughter decided, I'm going to go back to college. I said, how can you go to college when you're pregnant? Gonna have two little kids and go to college. So she says, I'm going to do it online. She would put them girls to bed, and then she would go online and do her college, and she got her associates degree
她正在茁壮成长。她遇到了她未来的丈夫，并且怀上了双胞胎。我女儿决定，我要回大学读书。我说，你怀孕了怎么能上大学呢？要带两个小孩还要上大学。所以她说，我要在网上完成。她会把那两个女孩哄睡着，然后她就会上网学习，她获得了商业副学士学位。
in business. So from there, from that, she moved up again and went to administrative assistant. And my daughter was making good money, really good money. They were proud. Pete says Alicia was the first person in his family to graduate from college. And a decade of hard work at Ford Detrick had paid off. And I mean things were going real good for.
所以从那里，从那以后，她再次晋升，成为了行政助理。我女儿赚的钱不错，真的赚了很多钱。他们很自豪。皮特说艾丽西亚是他家里第一个大学毕业生。在福特德特里克十年的努力工作得到了回报。我的意思是，事情对她来说进展得非常顺利。
But Alicia also had scoliosis. And as the years went by, it got worse. Of course, she had back problems. And of course, she went to the doctor and they put her own oxycodone. It's a story of our time. Aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, aaaaaah, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, She had split from her husband and was in the midst of a divorce. She had moved back in with Pete and Hope and the twins lived there too, part of the time. The oxycodone didn't just help with the back pain. It made Alicia feel better about everything. Then one day, Hope realized her own pain pills, the one she had been prescribed following
但艾丽西亚也患有脊柱侧弯。随着岁月的流逝，情况变得更糟了。当然，她有背部问题。当然，她去看医生，他们给她开了羟考酮（oxycodone）。这是一个属于我们这个时代的故事。她和丈夫分居了，正处于离婚的过程中。她搬回了皮特和霍普家，双胞胎也有一部分时间住在那儿。羟考酮不仅有助于缓解背痛。它让艾丽西亚对一切感觉都更好。有一天，霍普发现她自己的止痛药，也就是她在肩袖手术后被开的药，
a rotator cuff surgery, were running suspiciously low. I would leave my pills set on the counter, and then I could see that maybe one, two pills are being taken, and I'm not taking them. Well then I really started counting. I would actually start writing them down when I would take my pills and my pills should be lasted me longer. And of course I approached my daughter one day and she said, well mom my friend needed. He's having back troubles so my friend needed the ping-pill. I said you don't take't take my pink pills. You come to me first
少得可疑。我会把药放在柜台上，然后我可以看到可能有一两片药被拿走了，而我并没有吃它们。好吧，然后我真的开始数了。我实际上开始在我吃药时把它们写下来，我的药应该能让我吃得更久。当然，有一天我找我女儿谈了，她说，嗯，妈妈，我的朋友需要。他背部有问题，所以我的朋友需要止痛药。我说你不能拿我的粉色药片。你先来找我
and ask me. Looking back on it, hope things Alicia was already hooked. They were signs. Like her work, born to work late, saying, um, mom, I need to use this extra time from work. I have all this vacation time. I need to use some of this time from work. I have all this vacation time. I need to use some of this time from work. I would myself would take the girls down the school, drop them off. Notice that more and more she was like, well, I will be late, that can you do this. And I'm like, we are already late for work. Soon skipped hours, tonned into skipped days. I told her one day, I said, you're going to end up losing your job. You got a very good job.
问我。回想起来，霍普认为艾丽西亚已经上瘾了。有迹象。比如她的工作，总是加班，说，嗯，妈妈，我需要用这些额外的工作时间。我有这么多假期。我需要用掉一些工作时间。我需要用掉一些工作时间。我自己会带女孩们去学校，送她们下车。注意到她越来越多地说，嗯，我会迟到的，你能做这个吗。我说，我们上班已经迟到了。很快，旷工几小时变成了旷工几天。有一天我告诉她，我说，你会丢掉工作的。你有一份非常好的工作。
Don't mess it up. But she did after a while, and they left her go from Ford Dietrich. And then things just got worse. She just had a real hard time, what I want to say, functioning. She just couldn't seem to get herself together to be able to even with her girls. Eventually she lost shed custody of the twins. She was able to get her girls if she would do p-test. If she could get a cleaning yard,
别搞砸了。但过了一段时间她还是搞砸了，他们让她离开了福特德特里克。然后事情变得更糟了。她真的很难，怎么说呢，正常生活。她似乎无法振作起来，甚至无法照顾她的女孩们。最终她失去了双胞胎的监护权。如果她能通过尿检，她就能见到她的女孩们。如果她能找到清洁工作，
she could visit her girls at the Department of Social Services. It was after one of these visits that Hopen Pete believed Alicia finally lost whatever will she had to keep her life together. She drew in with her parents for a supervised visit, Hopen Pete waited in the car. They watched Alicia walk inside, her arms filled with toys. But when she came out of there, I could see her failing because she came out and she was
她可以在社会服务部探望她的女孩们。就是在其中一次探望之后，霍普和皮特相信艾丽西亚终于失去了维持生活的意志。她和父母一起去进行监督探视，霍普和皮特在车里等。他们看着艾丽西亚走进去，怀里抱着玩具。但当她从里面出来时，我能看出她崩溃了，因为她出来时
really crying. She said that they won't even let me hug them. They won't even let me kiss them. And that took my daughter downhill. And she came out there with her toys. The girls didn't want the toys, didn't want to get close to her. They left early. And when she came out that day, that in my heart,
真的在哭。她说他们甚至不让我拥抱她们。他们甚至不让我亲吻她们。这让我女儿陷入了低谷。她带着玩具从那里出来。女孩们不想要那些玩具，不想靠近她。她们提前离开了。那天她出来的时候，在我心里，
and I believe 100% that that was the turn around point for her to get on a heroin. Once Alicia started using heroin, she lost the remnants of her former life. First went, the last few rights she had left as a mother. The last time was in court, the judge wouldn't even allow our daughter to talk to her girls on the phone.
我相信100%那就是她开始吸食海洛因的转折点。一旦艾丽西亚开始吸食海洛因，她就失去了过去生活的残余。首先失去的是她作为母亲仅存的最后一点权利。最后一次是在法庭上，法官甚至不允许我们的女儿在电话里和她的女孩们说话。
And I'm like, people in prison get to talk to their kids on the phone. So why did the judge not want to? Sometimes they felt when she did talk to the girls on the phone that either she was nodding out or her speech was slurred. It's hard. I know it's hard for families with this situation, with the drugs. But when you have an addict, you have to help this person. But most people simply turned away from Alicia.
我说，监狱里的人都能在电话里和他们的孩子说话。那么为什么法官不想呢？有时他们觉得当她在电话里和女孩们说话时，要么她在打瞌睡，要么她说话含糊不清。这很难。我知道对于处于这种情况、有毒品的家庭来说这很难。但当你有一个瘾君子时，你必须帮助这个人。但大多数人只是简单地背弃了艾丽西亚。
Isolated and addicted, she burned through her savings. She got evicted from her apartment. She also started a new relationship and got pregnant. She was a six months about the time then. And I told her I said, Alicia, you have to get straight now. But she just couldn't. She could not help herself. She had gone to rehab and she was only there five days and she left. She just couldn't do it. But Pieden Hope kept fighting for that child.
孤立无援且成瘾，她花光了积蓄。她被赶出了公寓。她还开始了一段新的恋情并怀孕了。那时她大约怀孕六个月了。我告诉她，我说，艾丽西亚，你现在必须戒掉。但她就是做不到。她无法自拔。她去过康复中心，只待了五天就离开了。她就是做不到。但皮特和霍普一直在为那个孩子而战。
They worked with her, pleaded with her. Finally, something shifted in Alicia. She went back into rehab. This time, she made it through the 28-day program covered by Medicaid. When she came out, Pieden hoped to open their doors to her. She was seven months pregnant and very fragile. She was home a week. She's doing great. She shopped for baby clothes. She watched TV at night with her parents. She met a friend for lunch. She and her dad had an honest talk. Pete told her
他们和她一起努力，恳求她。终于，艾丽西亚身上发生了一些转变。她回到了康复中心。这一次，她完成了医疗补助覆盖的28天计划。当她出来时，皮特和霍普向她敞开了大门。她怀孕七个月了，非常脆弱。她回家一周了。她表现得很好。她买了婴儿衣服。她晚上和父母一起看电视。她和朋友吃了午饭。她和父亲进行了一次诚实的谈话。皮特告诉她
that he loved her. Alicia said she was sorry for all she'd put them through. One night hope fix Alicia, her favorite meal, corn beef and cabbage. And she was so happy that night. Matter of fact, after we got done dinner, I went back with her. She had these little boy clothes, and her and I was phoned him up and put them away. And she was going to name the little boy Camden, was his name. And her and I were sitting there, like my husband said, he'd come back there. And he told her that he loved her and that everything was going to work out. We all were working together. And we were all working together. sitting there like my husband said he'd come back there and he told her that he loved her and that everything was going to work out. We all were going to work together. Eventually, Hope and Pete went to bed. In the morning, Hope walked to Alicia's room
他爱她。艾丽西亚说她很抱歉让他们经历了这一切。一天晚上，霍普为艾丽西亚做了她最喜欢的饭菜，咸牛肉和卷心菜。那天晚上她很高兴。事实上，吃完晚饭后，我和她一起回去了。她有这些小男孩的衣服，她和我把它们折好收起来。她打算给小男孩取名叫卡姆登（Camden）。她和我坐在那里，就像我丈夫说的那样，他回到后面。他告诉她他爱她，一切都会好起来的。我们都在一起努力。我们都在一起努力。坐在那里，就像我丈夫说的那样，他回到后面，他告诉她他爱她，一切都会好起来的。我们都要一起努力。最终，霍普和皮特上床睡觉了。早上，霍普走到艾丽西亚的房间
to bring her the medicine she took to stave off withdrawal symptoms. And I went in and her light was on and I went in, opened the door. And then I saw her. And she was slumped over. I had her deletia. And she did not answer. And I had her for my husband to come running. And he went around where she was at and tried to pull her back. And she was at and tried to pull her back and she was already stiff. So when I called 911, they told us to try to get her on the floor and you give her compressions. And I told the woman, I said, man, she's gone. I knew she's gone. I know she's gone. Camden was also dead.
给她拿她用来缓解戒断症状的药。我进去了，她的灯亮着，我进去了，打开门。然后我看到了她。她瘫倒在那里。我叫了艾丽西亚。她没有回答。我让我丈夫跑过来。他绕到她所在的地方，试图把她拉回来。他绕到她所在的地方，试图把她拉回来，她已经僵硬了。所以我打911时，他们告诉我们试着把她放到地板上，给她做按压。我告诉那个女人，我说，女士，她走了。我知道她走了。我知道她走了。卡姆登也死了。
Alicia Troxill was 34 years old. She left behind her twin daughters, her parents, her brother. Hope and Pete wouldn't allow an autopsy because they didn't want to disturb their unborn grandchild. Hope says blood test showed Alicia had taken a deadly dose of fentanyl. Having just finished rehab, she was especially vulnerable to an overdose because her body had just been detoxed. Alicia's addiction didn't just kill her.
艾丽西亚·特罗克西尔年仅34岁。她留下了她的双胞胎女儿、她的父母和她的兄弟。霍普和皮特不允许进行尸检，因为他们不想打扰他们未出生的孙子。霍普说血液检查显示艾丽西亚服用了致命剂量的芬太尼。刚结束康复治疗，她特别容易过量，因为她的身体刚刚排毒。艾丽西亚的毒瘾不仅杀死了她。
It destroyed the family. Hope and Pete no longer have any contact with their granddaughters. It's something that hopes struggles with. My daughter's viewing that night before. It was so amazing. There was over 150 people there. And I wish my granddaughters could have seen that. They could have seen how loved her.
它摧毁了这个家庭。霍普和皮特不再与他们的孙女有任何联系。这是霍普一直在挣扎的事情。那天晚上我女儿的遗体瞻仰。太令人惊叹了。有超过150人在那里。我希望我的孙女们能看到。她们本可以看到她有多被爱。
My daughter was. I had loved their grandparents were. Hope's grief feels like a physical presence. Thinking the air, hard to move through. We all still whole family. I feel like... I have lost my granddaughters, which was... all I had left of my daughter. Thank you. Elisha's story took place 72,000 times in 2017.
我女儿有多被爱。她们的祖父母有多爱她们。霍普的悲伤感觉像是一种物理存在。充斥在空气中，难以呼吸。我们所有人，整个家庭。我觉得……我失去了我的孙女们，那是我……我女儿留给我的全部。谢谢。艾丽西亚的故事在2017年发生了72,000次。
To thousands of families, rich and poor, black and white and brown. The scale of this tragedy has generated horror and desperation. Legislators, communities and families have tried everything to stop the deaths. And then a few years ago something appeared that looked and sounded to many people like a miracle. Heroin sets off a chain reaction in the body. Up to a point, it makes users feel euphoric. It takes away stress and pain. But then, if you increase the dose, Herel heroin begins to affect vital functions.
发生在成千上万个家庭身上，无论贫富，无论肤色。这场悲剧的规模引发了恐惧和绝望。立法者、社区和家庭尝试了一切方法来阻止死亡。然后几年前，出现了一些东西，在许多人看来就像奇迹一样。海洛因在体内引发连锁反应。在一定程度上，它让使用者感到欣快。它消除了压力和痛苦。但随后，如果你增加剂量，海洛因开始影响重要功能。
The person's system slows down to a point where they stop breathing and then their brain basically shuts down. Leo Belatsky is a drug policy and public health researcher at Northeastern University. And that process typically takes a substantial period of time with traditional opioids, it can be up to two hours or more. Often, heroin sold on the streets is now laced with fentanyl and carfentanyl. These synthetic opioids are cheaper and stronger. So overdose can occur in a matter of minutes. can occur in a matter of minutes. Now there has long been a way to reverse overdoses. The drug Naloxone. Between 1996 and 2014, the CDC estimates that more than 26,000 overdoses
人的系统减慢到停止呼吸的地步，然后他们的大脑基本上就关闭了。利奥·贝莱茨基（Leo Belatsky）是东北大学的药物政策和公共卫生研究员。这个过程通常需要相当长的时间，对于传统的阿片类药物，可能长达两个小时或更长时间。通常，街头出售的海洛因现在掺杂了芬太尼和卡芬太尼。这些合成阿片类药物更便宜、更强效。因此，过量服用可能在几分钟内发生。可能在几分钟内发生。现在长期以来有一种逆转过量的方法。药物纳洛酮。在1996年至2014年间，疾控中心估计超过26,000例过量
were reversed by lay people administering Naloxone. Not medics, not doctors, ordinary people. Naloxone has been given the nickname, the Lazarus drug. In the Bible, Jesus restores life to Lazarus. Naloxone doesn't restore the dead, but it comes close. What happens is the person slowly starts to, their breathing starts to return to normal. Their skin starts to turn from its kind of white ash and color, which is what happens during
被普通人使用纳洛酮逆转了。不是医务人员，不是医生，而是普通人。纳洛酮被赋予了一个绰号，叫“拉撒路药物”（Lazarus drug）。在圣经中，耶稣让拉撒路复活。纳洛酮不能让死人复活，但它很接近。发生的情况是，这个人开始慢慢地，他们的呼吸开始恢复正常。他们的皮肤开始从那种灰白色的颜色中恢复，这是在
an overdose, and lips start to return from blue to normal color, and they start breathing again. In late 2015, the Food and Drug Administration approved a new form of naloxone that was much easier to use. It was a nasal spray, and it was a game changer. It was called Narcan. And it came at a critical time. Dets from drug overdoses was skyrocketing. Across the country, massive education campaigns spread the word about the magic drug.
过量服用期间发生的情况，嘴唇开始从蓝色恢复到正常颜色，他们又开始呼吸了。2015年底，美国食品药品监督管理局批准了一种更容易使用的新型纳洛酮。它是一种鼻喷雾剂，是一个游戏规则改变者。它被称为纳洛酮（Narcan）。它出现在一个关键时刻。药物过量死亡人数正在飙升。在全国范围内，大规模的教育运动传播了关于这种神奇药物的消息。
We'll go ahead and start before I start if you could pass your application's forward. On a Thursday morning, I'm in a packed conference room at a Maryland County Health Department. About 30 people sit in three rows. They fall silent as a woman steps to the front. So my name is Jasmine Pierce. I'm the overdose response coordinator
我们开始吧，在开始之前，如果你们能把申请表传上来。周四早上，我正在马里兰州卫生部的一个拥挤的会议室里。大约30人坐在三排。当一名女子走到前面时，他们安静了下来。我叫贾斯敏·皮尔斯（Jasmine Pierce）。我是过量反应协调员
for the Anorondal County Department of Health. You all are here for the Naloxone Narcan Training. This training should be about 30 to 30. It's a free training event for the community that officials hold a couple of times a month. People are here to learn how to administer Narcan to overdose victims. At the end of this training you will receive an Aloxone kit. This kit has two doses of intranasal
安妮阿伦德尔县卫生局的。你们都是来参加纳洛酮/纳洛酮培训的。这个培训应该在30到30分钟左右。这是一个免费的社区培训活动，官员们每月举办几次。人们来这里学习如何给过量受害者使用纳洛酮。培训结束时，您将收到一个纳洛酮套件。这个套件有两个剂量的鼻内
and Aloxone. We give two now due to the car fentanyl and fentanyl overdoses that have occurred within our county. Fentanyl and car fentanyl are so powerful that it often takes more than one dose of Narcan to bring a victim back. If you're not familiar with carpentinol that is a tranquilizer used to put large animals down such as elephants. A grain of small as a piece of salt can kill a human and it is 10,000 times more potent than morphine. I always mention that we do provide gloves inside of the kids as well to protect you from any type of contamination because with both of those drugs they can actually seep through your skin with skin-to- skin contact and you can overdose yourself. The CDC says the risk of overdose from such contact is very low.
纳洛酮。我们现在给两剂是因为我们县内发生的卡芬太尼和芬太尼过量事件。芬太尼和卡芬太尼太强大了，通常需要不止一剂纳洛酮才能让受害者恢复过来。如果你不熟悉卡芬太尼，那是一种用于放倒大象等大型动物的镇静剂。一粒盐那么小，就能杀死一个人，而且它的效力是吗啡的10,000倍。我总是提到，我们在套件内也提供了手套，以保护您免受任何类型的污染，因为这两种药物实际上可以通过皮肤接触渗入您的皮肤，您自己也可能过量。疾控中心表示，这种接触导致过量的风险非常低。
As Jasmine Pierce continues with the training, the people sitting in the three rows listen intently. Some look shocked, some take notes. There's a high school nurse, a minister, an athletic trainer, a mother, a friend, and lots of heartbreak. After the training session, their stories come tumbling out. My friend Jeff, his knee- niece died of a heroin overdose. Since the front of lines, Godson died and then my son died. He was 22, you know, and he just couldn't, didn't want to stop.
当贾斯敏·皮尔斯继续培训时，坐在三排的人们专心地听着。有些人看起来很震惊，有些人做笔记。有一名高中护士、一名牧师、一名运动教练、一位母亲、一位朋友，还有很多心碎的故事。培训结束后，他们的故事倾泻而出。我的朋友杰夫，他的侄女死于海洛因过量。从前线开始，教子死了，然后我儿子死了。他22岁，你知道，他就是不能，不想停下来。
That's what it falls down to. And he had already overdosed like five times the sheet. So he knew it was, he was playing Russian roulette. And then my sister, she was playing Russian roulette. And then my sister, she had overdose in October. She came back, they were able to bring her back with the Narcan. And then last month, she died of an overdose at work on break.
这就是问题的所在。他已经过量了五次。所以他知道，他在玩俄罗斯轮盘赌。然后我姐姐，她在玩俄罗斯轮盘赌。然后我姐姐，她在十月份过量了。她回来了，他们能够用纳洛酮把她救回来。然后上个月，她在工作休息时死于过量。
The trainer, Jasmine Pierce, has her own story. It's the one story everyone here wants to be able to tell. The story with a happy ending. I was going to 7-11 one morning before work and I noticed there was a man in his car. He looked like he was sleeping but I started to get a little worried because when I came back out, he looked blue to me. So I knocked on his window, he didn't respond. So thankfully, his door was open. I opened his door, I checked his pulse, and I noticed that he was unconscious, and I
培训师贾斯敏·皮尔斯有她自己的故事。这是这里每个人都想讲述的故事。一个有圆满结局的故事。一天早上上班前，我正要去7-11，我注意到一个男人在他的车里。他看起来像是在睡觉，但我开始有点担心，因为当我出来时，他看起来脸色发青。所以我敲了他的窗户，他没有反应。谢天谢地，他的车门开着。我打开他的车门，检查了他的脉搏，我注意到他昏迷了，我
didn't even think I just went ahead and sprayed the narcan, and within 30 seconds he came back. This is the power of the Lazarus drug. Across the country, legislators have rushed to pass laws, increasing access to an Aloxone. Some have urged every family in America to keep the drug closed at hand. Public health officials have assured people that if the administer an Aloxone to someone who is not high on opioids, it won't do anything. With most drugs, you have to worry about misuse and unintended consequences.
甚至没想，我只是直接喷了纳洛酮，30秒内他就恢复了。这就是“拉撒路药物”的力量。在全国范围内，立法者竞相通过法律，增加获得纳洛酮的机会。一些人敦促美国的每个家庭都把这种药放在手边。公共卫生官员向人们保证，如果他们给没有吸食阿片类药物的人使用纳洛酮，它不会有任何作用。对于大多数药物，你必须担心滥用和意外后果。
That wasn't true of Naloxone. But then, in early 2018, a study came out that suggested Naloxone might indeed have an unintended consequence. One so cruel that had called into question all the good the drug was doing. This finding set off an uproar with many experts rejecting its conclusions. The controversy reflects the mind-boggling complexities of the opioid epidemic and the labyrinth that confronts anyone who finds themselves in this world.
纳洛酮并非如此。但随后，在2018年初，一项研究出炉，暗示纳洛酮确实可能产生意想不到的后果。后果如此残酷，以至于它质疑了这种药物所做的一切好事。这一发现引发了轩然大波，许多专家拒绝接受其结论。这场争议反映了阿片类药物流行病的复杂性，以及任何发现自己处于这个世界的人所面临的迷宫。
The growing interest and public push to broaden access to Naloxone has been really interesting to me for a while. This again is Texas A&M economics professor Jennifer Dolyak. Jennifer and a colleague economist Anita Mukherjee from the University of Wisconsin knew that Naloxone was effective but there are always trade-offs. That's something we think about all the time as economists. What are the trade-offs involved? The biggest trade-off Jennifer and Anita were interested in was moral hazard. So when it's less risky to consume opioids because Naloxone provides a safety net we might see opioid abuse increase. In other words, could having the safety net of Naloxone provides a safety net, we might see opioid abuse increase. In other words, could having the safety net of Naloxone prompt drug users to take more risks,
人们对扩大纳洛酮获取途径的兴趣和公众推动力对我来说已经很有趣一段时间了。这又是德克萨斯农工大学经济学教授詹妮弗·多利亚克。詹妮弗和威斯康星大学的经济学家同事安妮塔·穆克吉（Anita Mukherjee）知道纳洛酮是有效的，但总是有权衡。这是我们作为经济学家一直在思考的问题。涉及哪些权衡？詹妮弗和安妮塔感兴趣的最大权衡是道德风险。因此，当消费阿片类药物的风险降低时，因为纳洛酮提供了安全网，我们可能会看到阿片类药物滥用增加。换句话说，拥有纳洛酮的安全网是否会促使吸毒者承担更多风险，
like injecting bigger doses of heroin or stronger drugs like fentanyl? Answering such a question scientifically is very, very difficult. The ideal experiment would be to randomly assign Naloxone access to some states but not others. Obviously that's not happening here, but it's helpful to think about that ideal experiment because it gives you a treatment and control group. Since the ideal data were not available, Jennifer and Anita came up with an indirect way to measure where the Naloxone use was affecting opioid use. Some states were passing laws, making it easier to get Naloxone use was affecting opioid use. Some states were passing laws making it easier to get Naloxone. The researchers decided to use these new laws as a proxy for people actually using Naloxone and then compared states that had broadened access with those
比如注射更大剂量的海洛因或更强效的药物，如芬太尼？科学地回答这样一个问题非常非常困难。理想的实验是将纳洛酮的获取途径随机分配给一些州，而不是其他州。显然这在这里没有发生，但思考那个理想的实验很有帮助，因为它给了你一个实验组和对照组。由于没有理想的数据，詹妮弗和安妮塔想出了一种间接的方法来衡量纳洛酮的使用是否影响了阿片类药物的使用。一些州正在通过法律，使获得纳洛酮变得更容易。研究人员决定利用这些新法律作为人们实际使用纳洛酮的代理指标，然后比较了扩大获取途径的州和那些
that had not. They would then test if there was any difference between these two groups in terms of opioid overdoses and mortality. It was an imperfect experiment, but this was the data they had. Well, even that, you know, it's not random, and so we need to we need to be really careful about making sure we're controlling for everything else that might be going on in those states that we think might have an impact control for pre-existing trends, control for just
没有扩大的州。然后他们会测试这两组在阿片类药物过量和死亡率方面是否有任何差异。这是一个不完美的实验，但这就是他们拥有的数据。好吧，即使那样，你知道，它不是随机的，所以我们需要非常小心，确保我们控制了这些州可能发生的其他所有我们认为可能会产生影响的事情，控制预先存在的趋势，控制
pre-existing trends, control for just pre-existing differences across states and levels of opioid use and other policies they might have implemented to address the crisis. With all those controls in place, they thought they may be able to answer the question, what effect was Naloxone having on the heroin epidemic? On net, was it saving lives? It seems reasonable that a drug that saves lives, you know, would, would, on average, have
预先存在的趋势，控制各州之间预先存在的差异以及阿片类药物的使用水平，以及他们可能实施的其他旨在解决危机的政策。在所有这些控制措施到位的情况下，他们认为他们也许能够回答这个问题，纳洛酮对海洛因流行病产生了什么影响？总的来说，它是在挽救生命吗？一种挽救生命的药物，你知道，在查看死亡率时，平均而言会产生
beneficial effects when you look at mortality rates. I think when we first got into this taper, we really expected to see a big drop in opioid related mortality as a result of these laws. But that is not what they found. In fact, what we found was that on net, we're not seeing any decline in mortality and in some places we actually see an increase in mortality. It was a stunning result. To be fair, Jennifer and Anita found that some states did see a decline in mortality when
有益的影响，这似乎是合理的。我想当我们第一次进入这个课题时，我们真的期望看到由于这些法律，阿片类药物相关的死亡率会大幅下降。但那不是他们发现的。事实上，我们发现的是，总的来说，我们没有看到死亡率有任何下降，在某些地方我们实际上看到了死亡率的上升。这是一个令人震惊的结果。公平地说，詹妮弗和安妮塔发现一些州确实看到了死亡率的下降，当
they brought in access to an eloxone. But on average, nationwide, mortality did not decline. And in places like the Midwest. We're finding that the Naloxone-access laws caused a 14% increase in opioid-related mortality relative to what would have happened without the law and also a big increase in fentanyl-related mortality, again relative to the counterfactual what would have happened without the law. Jennifer and Anita have a theory about what is going on. Our interpretation is that the risk of death associated with a kind of unit use of heroin or prescription pills has fallen now due to an allocone, but the number of uses and the potency of
他们引入了纳洛酮的获取途径。但平均而言，在全国范围内，死亡率并没有下降。在中西部等地区。我们发现纳洛酮获取法导致阿片类药物相关死亡率比没有该法律的情况增加了14%，芬太尼相关死亡率也大幅增加，同样是相对于没有该法律的反事实情况。詹妮弗和安妮塔对正在发生的事情有一个理论。我们的解释是，与海洛因或处方药单位使用相关的死亡风险现在由于纳洛酮而下降了，但使用的次数和效力
uses has gone up so much that it actually, it doesn't just reduce the mortality benefits, but it completely counteracts them in the Midwest in particular. And so what seems to be happening is that opioid use is going up so much as a result of broader access to naloxone that that we're actually seeing an increase in mortality rather than a decrease. Shortly after Jennifer and Anita disseminated a working paper about their
增加了这么多，以至于它实际上不仅减少了死亡率的好处，而且在中西部地区完全抵消了它们。所以似乎发生的情况是，由于纳洛酮的获取途径更广，阿片类药物的使用增加得如此之多，以至于我们实际上看到了死亡率的上升而不是下降。在詹妮弗和安妮塔传播了一份关于他们的
results, the pushback came fast and hard from public health experts. Critics pointed to studies that had reached very different conclusions. At the University of Colorado, Denver, for example, Daniel Rees and his colleagues found that a state's expanded access to Naloxone, there was about a 10% decline in mortality. And at the Federal Substance Abuse and Mental Health Services Administration, Chandler McLellan and his colleagues found an even bigger decline in mortality between the early 2000s and 2014.
结果的工作论文后不久，公共卫生专家迅速而强烈地进行了反击。批评者指出了得出完全不同结论的研究。例如，在科罗拉多大学丹佛分校，丹尼尔·里斯（Daniel Rees）和他的同事发现，一个州扩大了纳洛酮的获取途径，死亡率下降了约10%。而在联邦药物滥用和心理健康服务管理局，钱德勒·麦克莱伦（Chandler McLellan）和他的同事发现，在21世纪初到2014年之间，死亡率下降幅度更大。
Public Health Research, Leo Beletski, says Jennifer Anitas paper was based on flawed assumptions and flawed methodology. It's basically what computer scientists call garbage in garbage out. For one thing Leo says, the paper argued that state laws expanding the lock zone access sign, and increased availability of naloxone in those states. But Leo says, this is wrong. Laws making drugs more available, and a drug actually being available, are two different things. So let's say, you know, the state of New York, does the state of New York have a naloxone law, or doesn't it have the law, is not necessarily a proxy for whether or not an
公共卫生研究员利奥·贝莱茨基说，詹妮弗和安妮塔的论文基于错误的假设和错误的方法论。这基本上就是计算机科学家所说的“垃圾进，垃圾出”。利奥说，首先，这篇论文认为州法律扩大了纳洛酮的获取途径，并增加了这些州纳洛酮的可用性。但利奥说，这是错误的。使药物更容易获得的法律，与药物实际可用，是两码事。所以假设，你知道，纽约州，纽约州有纳洛酮法，还是没有法律，并不一定能代表纳洛酮是否
Aloxone is available on the streets of New York State. Leo has worked on getting such laws passed. You can say with certainty that in many cases the presence of the law was actually a consequence of an Aloxone being available in some areas. So, you know, in New York City, being available in some areas. So, you know, in New York City, Naloxone distribution started back in the late 1990s, for example. The first Naloxone law in New York State was passed in 2013. Now it's worth noting that this critique of Jennifer and Anita's paper also applies in part to the papers we mentioned that found that Naloxone reduced mortality. Leo says Jennifer and Anita's paper,
在纽约州的街头可用。利奥致力于推动此类法律的通过。你可以肯定地说，在许多情况下，法律的存在实际上是纳洛酮在某些地区可用的一种结果。所以，你知道，在纽约市，纳洛酮的分发始于20世纪90年代末，例如。纽约州的第一部纳洛酮法于2013年通过。现在值得注意的是，对詹妮弗和安妮塔论文的这种批评也部分适用于我们提到的发现纳洛酮降低死亡率的论文。利奥说詹妮弗和安妮塔的论文，
not only misconstrues what's happening on the ground, but jeopardizes hard-won advances. We have worked for a long time to get these Naloxone laws passed, and in many cases, there was a lot of resistance based on the moral hazard argument in the legislatures to get these naloxon laws passed. It was only the skyrocketing death toll that caused lawmakers to act.
不仅曲解了实地正在发生的事情，而且危及了来之不易的进展。我们长期以来一直致力于通过这些纳洛酮法，在许多情况下，立法机构中基于道德风险论点的阻力很大，才得以通过这些纳洛酮法。只有飙升的死亡人数才促使立法者采取行动。
Leo worries that the moral hazard paper will cause legislatures to pull back. Jennifer and Anita stand by their results. It's not lost on us at all that these are lives that we're talking about and that the increase in mortality that we're seeing, you know, these are actual people who have lost their lives due to addiction. And it's depressing just how with so many smart people thinking about this, it feels like we're no closer to solving the problem. The truth is, we don't fully understand how addiction works.
利奥担心道德风险论文会导致立法机构退缩。詹妮弗和安妮塔坚持他们的结果。我们完全没有忘记我们谈论的是生命，我们看到的死亡率上升，你知道，这些是因成瘾而失去生命的真实的人。令人沮丧的是，有这么多聪明人思考这个问题，感觉我们离解决这个问题并没有更近。事实是，我们并不完全了解成瘾是如何运作的。
We are still figuring out how to help people quit. We have trouble identifying even what's happening in the course of an epidemic because addiction is stigmatized and people can't talk honestly about their behavior. The data are incredibly messy, regardless of whether you are wearing the hat of an economist like Jennifer Dolyak or a public health scholar like Leo Beletski. At the same time that states were expanding access to Naloxone for example, there was an influx of powerful synthetic opioids into the country. Heroin is increasingly laced with them.
我们仍在研究如何帮助人们戒瘾。我们甚至难以确定流行病过程中发生了什么，因为成瘾被污名化了，人们无法诚实地谈论他们的行为。数据非常混乱，无论你是戴着像詹妮弗·多利亚克这样的经济学家的帽子，还是像利奥·贝莱茨基这样的公共卫生学者的帽子。例如，在各州扩大纳洛酮获取途径的同时，大量强效合成阿片类药物涌入该国。海洛因越来越多地掺杂了它们。
It's possible the recent rise in opioid deaths was driven by the surge in synthetic drugs that have flooded the streets. It isn't just families and researchers and policy makers who are grappling with these life and death issues. Drug users engage in these debates as well, families and researchers and policymakers who are grappling with these life and death issues. Drug users engage in these debates as well, using a mental calculus of their own. People that have mentioned they got that on Bad Batch app now on your phone and people pin where bad batches of dope are. And there's people that download that just to go find the bad batches and do it.
阿片类药物死亡人数的近期上升，可能是由充斥街头的合成毒品激增所驱动的。不仅是家庭、研究人员和政策制定者在努力应对这些生死攸关的问题。吸毒者也参与了这些辩论，他们有着自己的心理算计。人们提到他们手机上现在有那个“坏批次”应用程序，人们会在上面标记哪里有劣质毒品。有些人下载它只是为了去寻找那些劣质毒品并使用它们。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Coming up, the dangerous logic that seeks to balance the risk of death with Euphoria. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. On the day that I attended the Narcan Training at the Anarandal County Department of Health, I met two people who'd come to the on-site clinic for their daily dose of methadone. It's a drug that helps reduce withdrawal symptoms from heroin. One person was using it to stay off heroin, the other to keep from using too much.
是的。是的。是的。接下来，我们将探讨试图在死亡风险与快感之间取得平衡的危险逻辑。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我参加安妮阿伦德尔县卫生局纳洛酮培训的那天，我遇到了两个人，他们来到现场诊所领取每日剂量的美沙酮。这是一种有助于减轻海洛因戒断症状的药物。其中一人用它来戒掉海洛因，另一人则用它来防止过量使用。
We sat down at a picnic bench to chat. We'll only be using their first names. My name is James. Let me get you to tell me your name please. Tiffany. Tiffany is 24 with dark hair and glasses. James is 59, graying and weathered. They should have
我们坐在野餐长椅上聊天。我们只使用他们的名字。我叫詹姆斯。请告诉我你的名字。蒂芙尼。蒂芙尼24岁，留着深色头发，戴着眼镜。詹姆斯59岁，头发花白，饱经风霜。他们本应该
little and common, and yet their stories are painfully similar. James started using heroin when he was just 13, a poor kid he says from his Baltimore. Well, when we grew up, my father left us, my mother. He had six children and my father left us with nothing. To help his mom, James says he started hustling on the streets and carrying guns for drug dealers. Then he started carrying that dope and using it. It made him feel better about his life. I didn't feel I didn't want to go to school, I hope school because all my clothes were all wholly this and all of them. My mother had to go to churches, to veterans store, just like a nickel pair of pants,
微不足道且平凡，但他们的故事却痛苦地相似。詹姆斯在13岁时就开始使用海洛因，他说他是一个来自巴尔的摩的穷孩子。嗯，当我们长大时，我父亲离开了我们，我母亲。她有六个孩子，我父亲什么也没给我们留下。为了帮助母亲，詹姆斯说他开始在街头混迹，并为毒贩携带枪支。然后他开始携带毒品并使用它。这让他对自己的生活感觉好了一些。我不想去上学，我讨厌学校，因为我的衣服都很破旧。我母亲不得不去教堂、去退伍军人商店，就像买几毛钱一条的裤子，
nickel pair shirt, sense and pair of shoes, you know, and you get tired of that. Tiffany started her drug habit at exactly the same age as James. I started doing, I started doing the percussettes when I was 13. And like James, she says she was pretty unhappy as a kid. Percussette filled the missing parts of her life. When the pills got harder to obtain, she moved on to heroin. And it was just easier to get and around more. It was cheaper. I mean, you really got higher off of it in the less amount.
几毛钱一件的衬衫，几分钱一双的鞋子，你知道，你会厌倦这些。蒂芙尼开始吸毒的年龄和詹姆斯完全一样。我13岁时就开始服用Percocet（止痛药）。和詹姆斯一样，她说她小时候很不快乐。Percocet填补了她生活中缺失的部分。当药片变得难以获得时，她转向了海洛因。它更容易获得，而且更便宜。我的意思是，你确实可以用更少的量获得更强的快感。
So. It's a logic that's common to opioid use. Some users would prefer heroin to percuss it because it's cheaper and stronger. And then they might prefer synthetic opioids to heroin for the very same reason. While public health officials warn about drugs like fentanyl, some users go looking for them. If they knew where the good dope was and people were falling out and dying from this shit,
所以，这是一种阿片类药物使用中常见的逻辑。一些使用者更喜欢海洛因而不是Percocet，因为它更便宜、更强效。然后他们可能会因为同样的原因更喜欢合成阿片类药物而不是海洛因。虽然公共卫生官员警告像芬太尼这样的药物，但一些使用者却主动寻找它们。如果他们知道哪里有好货，而人们因为这些东西倒下并死去，
they would run right to get so they would before they sold out. They would haul ass to get that shit and they figure, okay, well I'll just do a little bit so it won't hurt me. Yeah, there's plenty of people to do it. And if there's even people that have mentioned they got that on Bad Batch app now on your phone and people pin where Bad Batches of Doap are. And there's people that download that
他们会立刻跑去买，赶在卖光之前。他们会拼命去弄到那些东西，他们心想，好吧，我只要用一点点，它就不会伤害我。是的，有很多人这样做。甚至有人提到他们手机上现在有那个“坏批次”应用程序，人们会在上面标记哪里有劣质毒品。有些人下载它
just to go find the Bad band batches and do it. Tiffany is referring to a text messaging service that uses data from public health officials. She says that figuring out where the best dope is available at the cheapest price is part of the daily calculation of heroin use. For her part, she spent about $50 a day on her heroin habit. I know, I know $50 a day on her heroin habit. I know, I know $50, that's not really a lot compared to some people on it. I know some people that would be going through a deal or a habit.
只是为了去寻找那些劣质毒品并使用它们。蒂芙尼指的是一项使用公共卫生官员数据的短信服务。她说，弄清楚哪里能以最便宜的价格买到最好的毒品是海洛因使用者日常计算的一部分。就她而言，她每天花大约50美元在海洛因上。我知道，我知道每天50美元在海洛因上。我知道，我知道50美元，与某些人相比这真的不算多。我知道有些人每天的开销会更大。
Since he was selling the stuff himself, James had easy access to both money and dope. Sometimes, he'd take a little bit for himself before passing the rest on to his customers. There were a lot of moments like this when James and Tiffany rift off each other, building on their shared language of heroin. Another thing they share, they've both overdosed multiple times. The first time for Tiffany was when she was 17. I just didn't fell out. I don't remember. I know I was dead for four minutes by the time the ambulance got there,
由于他自己也在卖这些东西，詹姆斯很容易获得金钱和毒品。有时，他在把剩下的卖给客户之前，会给自己留一点。当詹姆斯和蒂芙尼互相交流，建立在他们共同的海洛因语言之上时，有很多这样的时刻。他们共同的另一件事是，他们都曾多次过量吸毒。蒂芙尼第一次是在她17岁时。我只是昏倒了。我不记得了。我知道在救护车到达时，我已经死了四分钟，
but they revived me with Narcan. You've seen it happen so many times. I've overdosed. Nine times. Me too old. Tiffany has overdosed nine times. James 12. They owe their lives to Narcan.
但他们用纳洛酮救活了我。你见过这种情况发生很多次。我过量吸毒了九次。我也是。蒂芙尼过量吸毒九次。詹姆斯12次。他们的生命归功于纳洛酮。
James says he now always keeps a life saving drug. Close at a hand. I got five or six nasal spray narcans up in my room. So if somebody falls out around me, ain't no amelams. I just take the narcan. It's like a nose. You know what I mean? You just put your whole your fingers on it. It looks like a long stem and it goes like that. And it's got another thing point comes down here
詹姆斯说他现在总是随身携带这种救命药。我的房间里有五六个鼻喷式纳洛酮。所以如果有人在我身边倒下，不需要救护车。我只是用纳洛酮。它就像一个鼻子。你知道我的意思吗？你只是把手指放在上面。它看起来像一个长柄，然后就这样。它还有另一个部分在下面，
that you push in. Like that. So you catch it when they're breathing in And then out then once they're breathing back in that's when they shoot shoot it up their nose Not even 10 15 seconds later. They're arrived. They're back It's some whoever made that Narcanus. Some has some serious Ways of saving people's lives. It's telling you But Narcan also does something unpleasant to users who are high. It brings them crashing down really fast.
你按下去。就像那样。所以当他们在吸气时你抓住时机，然后呼气，一旦他们恢复呼吸，那就是你把它喷进他们鼻子里的时候。不到10到15秒，他们就恢复了。他们回来了。制造纳洛酮的人真是太厉害了，有办法拯救人们的生命。它在告诉你。但纳洛酮对处于兴奋状态的使用者来说也会产生一些不愉快的影响。它让他们迅速从兴奋中跌落。
When you put that Narcan and you eat everything and any Narcanic, or anything you got in your system, it eats it all out. I mean, it's like scrubbing bubbles. It just goes right through you so fast. And that is not a good feeling. To go from a heroin high to an internal scrub feels awful. That's why many people who are revived with Narcan immediately try to get high again. Just when you went the first time this happened to you do you recall the the you obviously don't recall the Emergency people coming to your house, but you recall what happened right after
当你使用纳洛酮时，它会吃掉一切，任何纳洛酮，或者你系统里的任何东西，它都会把它全部清除。我的意思是，它就像洗涤泡沫。它穿过你的速度太快了。那感觉并不好。从海洛因的快感变成内部清洗感觉糟透了。这就是为什么许多被纳洛酮救活的人会立即尝试再次吸毒。当你第一次发生这种情况时，你还记得吗？你显然不记得急救人员来到你家，但你记得之后发生了什么吗？
I remember going in to the emergency room They sat there and I had to stay there until I was fully coherent Did you have a sense that you actually came close to dying? Yeah, I know As soon as I got out, I did more. I had every single time I overdosed. I did more as soon as I got out of the hospital. It was a revolving door. Heroin Overdoz Narcan. Heroin Overdoz Narcan. I asked Tiffany and James where the Narcan was causing users to take risks that they would not have taken otherwise.
我记得去了急诊室。他们让我坐在那里，直到我完全清醒。你有没有感觉到你真的差点死了？是的，我知道。我一出来，就用了更多。我每次过量吸毒后都是这样。我一出医院就用了更多。这是一个恶性循环。海洛因、过量、纳洛酮。海洛因、过量、纳洛酮。我问蒂芙尼和詹姆斯，纳洛酮是否导致使用者冒他们本不会冒的风险。
They rejected the idea that Narcan was the reason anyone would choose to get high, but they said the drug might affect how much heroin people use. Where I've noted people say, all right, I've got Narcan, right? They're just going to amp it up more. Tiffany has a friend who is quite explicit about what Narcan does for his drug habit. I know he's mentioned to me quite a few times that if he falls out, we'll come back. They'll come and give him Narcan and bring him back.
他们拒绝了纳洛酮是任何人选择吸毒的原因这一观点，但他们说这种药可能会影响人们使用海洛因的量。我注意到人们说，好吧，我有纳洛酮，对吧？他们只会加大剂量。蒂芙尼有一个朋友，他非常明确地说明了纳洛酮对他的毒瘾有什么作用。我知道他曾多次对我提到，如果他倒下了，我们会回来的。他们会来给他注射纳洛酮并让他恢复过来。
So would her friends stop using heroin if he didn't have Narcan? No. Very no way. Tiffany Seese, the moral hazard dilemma of heroin and Narcan. I think that it makes people not be as careful about it, but I also think that there ain't no way that they should take it away because then people are going to be drop and left and right look at everybody that it saves. And among the everybody that it saves is Tiffany.
那么如果他没有纳洛酮，她的朋友会停止使用海洛因吗？不会。绝对不会。蒂芙尼看到了海洛因和纳洛酮的道德风险困境。我认为这让人没那么小心了，但我也认为他们绝不应该取消它，因为那样人们会接二连三地倒下，看看它拯救了多少人。而在它拯救的所有人中，就包括蒂芙尼。
After multiple overdoses and a blood infection from shooting up that destroyed part of her heart, she finally had enough. I was just, I don't know, I was just done with that kind of life. Like I'm just really sat down and thought about it one day and how I imagined my life to be and who I was going to be. And I just wasn't how I wanted to live no more. And what did you...
在多次过量吸毒和因注射导致心脏部分受损的血液感染后，她终于受够了。我只是，我不知道，我只是厌倦了那种生活。有一天我真的坐下来思考，我想象我的生活应该是怎样的，我想成为什么样的人。我只是不想再那样生活了。那你……
When you thought about how you imagined your life was supposed to be and how it had turned out, what went through your head, what did you see in terms of what your life had become? Just everything that addiction does to you, like I wouldn't even mean no more. You do things that aren't you and knowing of how many times I've died, just none of it even made any sense to me. Tiffany now needs methadone to keep withdrawal at bay. She has a heart that beats only because
当你想到你想象中的生活应该是怎样的，而现实却变成了这样时，你脑子里在想什么？你看到了你的生活变成了什么样？只是成瘾对你所做的一切，就像我甚至不再是我自己了。你做的事情不是你，而且知道我死过多少次，这一切对我来说根本没有任何意义。蒂芙尼现在需要美沙酮来抑制戒断症状。她的心脏跳动仅仅是因为
the damaged portion was replaced with part of a cow's heart. But Tiffany is alive and at 24, she really does have a whole life ahead of her. She is grateful for the chance and would willingly give it to someone else. That's why, even though she isn't using anymore, she always makes sure she has an arcane, close at hand. Yeah, I don't want nothing to happen to somebody and me not be able to save them. I couldn't live with being able to see somebody die and know when it I could have did something. The opioid crisis in America is like a wildfire, racing through towns and cities, consuming individual lives and families and whole communities.
受损的部分被牛心的一部分所取代。但蒂芙尼还活着，24岁的她确实还有整个人生在等着她。她很感激这个机会，并愿意把它给别人。这就是为什么即使她不再吸毒，她也总是确保手边有纳洛酮。是的，我不想让别人出事而我却无法救他们。如果我能看到有人死去却知道我本可以做点什么，我无法忍受。美国的阿片类药物危机就像一场野火，在城镇和城市中蔓延，吞噬着个人的生命、家庭和整个社区。
Sometimes amidst all the smoke and fire, you can barely see what's going on. It's likely in the coming years there will be more hard data on the effects of Naloxo. For now, the best we can do is to come to terms with the trade-offs to accept that the interventions we develop to save people might sometimes lead to unintended and unwanted consequences. At those times, it's worth remembering what we are doing right. The people we pull from the flames, charred, damaged, but not yet destroyed. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenish Mett and Parth Shah.
有时在所有的烟雾和火焰中，你几乎看不清发生了什么。未来几年可能会有更多关于纳洛酮影响的硬数据。目前，我们能做的最好的事情就是接受权衡，接受我们为拯救人们而开发的干预措施有时可能会导致意想不到和不想要的后果。在那些时候，值得记住我们做对了什么。我们从火焰中拉出的人，烧焦了，受损了，但还没有被摧毁。本期《隐藏的大脑》由Jenish Mett和Parth Shah制作。
It was edited by Tara Boyle and Camilla Vargas Restrepo. Atim includes Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarral. Special thanks this week to Ashley Messenger, Mark Mehmet and Neil Karuth. Aronsang Hero this week is Ellen Jones, the public information director at the Anorando County Department of Health. Ellen invited us to sit in on one of the county's Narcan training sessions. She also encouraged community members to speak with us.
由Tara Boyle和Camilla Vargas Restrepo编辑。团队成员包括Raina Cohen、Thomas Liu和Laura Quarral。本周特别感谢Ashley Messenger、Mark Mehmet和Neil Karuth。本周的英雄是安妮阿伦德尔县卫生局的公共信息主任Ellen Jones。Ellen邀请我们参加了该县的一次纳洛酮培训课程。她还鼓励社区成员与我们交谈。
Ellen and her colleagues at the Anorandal County Department of Health are the front-line responders to the opioid epidemic. Even as we focus on helping families and those struggling with addiction, we should all be immensely grateful to folks like Ellen who are dealing with a difficult and heartbreaking job of keeping people alive. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please consider sharing it with a friend and then setting down to chat with your friend about your reactions to it. Good people will disagree when it comes to questions about moral hazard, but we will all be better off if
Ellen和她在安妮阿伦德尔县卫生局的同事是阿片类药物流行病的一线响应者。即使我们专注于帮助家庭和那些与成瘾作斗争的人，我们也应该对像Ellen这样正在处理让人们活下去这一困难且令人心碎的工作的人们心存感激。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请考虑与朋友分享，然后坐下来与你的朋友讨论你对它的反应。好人在道德风险问题上会有分歧，但如果我们能从他人的观点中学习，我们都会过得更好。
we can learn from the views of others. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。